rfm malfrats et autres casseurs de tout
poil attention danger
voilà ce qui vous attend si vous êtes
pris en flagrant délit de fuite cette
arme n'a pas vocation à tuer mais tirée
à bout portant
elle peut faire mal très mal ceci est
une arme de défense et de dissuasion
la cartouche qui est utilisé pour son
fonctionnement est d'un calibre 44
il s'agit d'une fosse d'où une plastique
si tu as une conception simple celle de
d'utilisation et qui nécessite de la
part des fonctionnaires qui vont
utiliser une formation une formation
très très soutenu et surtout permanente
afin que cette arme ne pose aucun
problème mais sa simplicité
d'utilisation il dans le maximum
d'efficacité aussi à son emploi le flash
ball ou lanceur de balles à mousser
destiné à équiper toutes les brigades
anti criminalité de france ministre de
l'intérieur a joué le père noël pour les
deux brigades spécialisées tarnaise un
cadeau pour les fonctionnaires de police
mais certainement pas pour les auteurs
de délits
l'idée en fait c'est de permettre aux
policiers qui se trouvent en situation
finalement délicate de pouvoir dans le
cas de légitime défense pouvoir
intervenir assez rapidement
évitez je dirais le tire larmes de feu
traditionnelles par les dégâts qu'elle
peut que que le tir de cette balle peut
occasionner et montrent à l'évidence
qu'il s'agit d'une arme quand même qui
est assez dangereuse et qui nécessite
une utilisation je dirais
très présente bref tarn et dormez en
paix les braqueurs n'ont qu'à bien se
tenir avec ce gros joujou les
fonctionnaires de police affectés à la
lutte contre la criminalité bénéficie de
moyens accrus pour mener à bien leur
mission
[Musique]